It's great to welcome to the program today,
David Roberts, who's a [inaudible]
journalists for Vox, focusing on climate change
and politics. And we're going to talk about,
uh, we're going to talk about a lot of different
things. David, great to have you on today.
Glad to be here.
So a lot of the folks in my audience have
been in a concerned manner following what
seems to be the sort of the irrelevance of
the truth as it may be in modern politics,
whether it's alternative facts, whether it's
there's nothing Donald Trump could ever do,
even hypothetically, that would make me reconsider
my support for him, which we heard is the
case for 62% of Trump supporters. Some are
just calling this a post truth status quo
in which we find ourselves, but is, is that
encompassing enough? How do you describe what
you see today? Is the relationship between
the sort of political world and the truth
as it is knowable?
Sure. Well, that's a, that's a, that's a lot,
but it's complicated. But I guess the way
I would put it is that, um, in any sort of
society or culture, there's a, uh, bedrock
of trust, what, what, what they call social
trust. Political scientists call it social
trust, which is just a sense that we're, we're
in this together, that we're part of, we're
there, we're part of a larger project together
and that whatever sacrifices we make for that
project, whatever restraints we put on ourselves
or whatever, um, you know, we have to do,
we get back from that project at, you know,
we get food, shelter, uh, a social belonging.
So social trust is sort of the basis, uh,
it turns out for everything for politics working.
Um, and it turns out even to be the basis
of, uh, our information system. So what we've
seen happen in the last several decades is,
uh, a sort of erosion of social trust in the
U S um, I have my own thoughts about who was,
who and what were the primary cause of that.
But the result is that the institution of
media, the institution of journalism, uh,
as it existed in postwar America, no longer
commands, widespread social trust. There,
there is a large faction of the country, 30,
40%, no one I think knows exactly how large
that simply does not accept what, uh, what
mainstream journalists journalism tells it
anymore and has now, um, you know, the, the,
the, the conservative movement lost trust
in mainstream media, separated from it more
or less went off and made its own kind of
fun house mirror version of journalism. But,
but it forgot to replicate what made journalism,
uh, work, which is some element of self-correction,
some sense that journalists are devoted to
principles beyond party, beyond faction, that
they're sort of answerable to higher principles
of, of evidence. And, you know, uh, getting
a, a, a second quote, all these sort of day
to day rules of journalism are meant to sort
of guard against tribalism, guard against
sort of like just telling a story.
That's whatever your audience wants to hear.
Uh, when the conservative movement sort of
made its own media, it dropped that part out.
And now we have what is effectively a second
competing media that is devoted just to telling
that audience what it wants to hear, not being
answerable to any principle above partisanship
or above a faction. So, so we have effectively
become as a, as a people incapable of knowing
things together, which turns out to be really
important to democracy. Really important to
doing anything together. The first step is
knowing things together and we become unable.
We now have a sort of a conservative media
apparatus that if it sets out to can shield
this 30 to 40% of the country from any information
it was, it doesn't matter how clear the information,
it doesn't matter, you know, sort of. Uh,
and I, and I wrote the article about impeachment,
which seems to me sort of a kind of the perfect
example of this.
I mean, the Trump administration cranks out
an example of this every, every day you could
point to, but impeachment, it seems to me,
uh, a poignant example in that the story about
what Trump did, selling, you know, withholding
aid to Ukraine in exchange for an investigation
of, of Biden is just really clear now. It's
just really obvious. We've had multiple, uh,
multiple direct testimony accounts. Trump
has admitted it multiple times before he figured
out he wasn't supposed to have done it. Multiple
administration officials have admitted to
it. It's got documentary evidence, there's
a, there's a log of the call on and on and
on. There's just this overwhelming pile of
information. It's just very obvious what he
did and why he did it. And yet, as obvious
as it is, there's 30 to 40% of the country
that doesn't know it, that believes all sorts
of weird talking to any other things about
a giant, deep, deep state conspiracy. And,
uh, you know, a, a server and Ukraine and
I don't even know all the, all the conspiracy
theories that are going on right now, but,
but the point is we've become incapable of
learning and knowing things together. So it's
not the truth is gone. The truth is out there
as they say. It's not the, it's not the nature
of truth as a problem. It is a social process
whereby we learn and accept and act on that
truth. That's what's
broken. One of the things that seems to have
helped some of these almost mean type narratives
take hold. Like for example, fake news is
that there's some kernel of sense in the idea,
for example, that Hey, we shouldn't just accept
what media tells us. Okay, great. That there's
a kernel of truth there. Sometimes opinion
and reporting are blurred to your disadvantage.
Absolutely. Right. I mean, that's how, that's,
that's a, uh, an important part of what Fox
news does. We should sometimes, uh, media
gets it wrong and so on, but then it becomes,
if it sounds like it's critical of Trump,
it must be untrue without requiring more examination.
And I think that's why it's so pernicious
because it starts with a kernel of responsibility
or truth and then goes completely off the
rails.
Yeah, no, I think that's totally right. And
I think if you go back and look at postwar
journalism in the U S you know, the conservative
movements critique was always that this journalist
class, especially as as the decades went on,
this sort of composed of people who come from
the liberal class, they're socially liberal.
They're basically, you know, they believe
in tolerance, they're, you know, moderates,
whatever. And that sometimes shades news coverage
in a way where conservatives felt like people
of their persuasion were not getting a voice.
There was always a kernel of truth to that.
But the question is, what do you do with that?
If, if, if, if the, if the problem is media
bias that sometimes ends up telling us that
it ends up going against us. What's the solution?
You can go two directions. You could go, let's
redouble out the, the, the rules and principles
that we use to guide journalism.
Let's redouble our commitment to fairness.
Let's redouble our commitment to hearing all
voices and balancing all voices, right? Or
you could go the other way. Here's a bias
news source that's telling us that's going
against us. Let's create a new source that
tells us what we want to hear, right? So the
problem that they identified, if you look
at what a, if you look at how they reacted,
right? They didn't react by going and creating
media with better guards against bias, right?
Against or better guards against unfairness.
They went and created media that dispense
with all guards against fairness and just
told conservatives what they wanted to hear,
right? So it's sad that looking back on it,
it sounds to me like it wasn't the bias that
was the problem. It was that the bias went
in the wrong direction for them. Right? Like
if you look at CNN and your complaint is that
it's not objective enough and then you go
create Fox, right? Maybe it wasn't the, the
objectivity, that was really the root of your
objection, right? More of the root of their
objection is just that we're not hearing what
we want. Like the, like the results, what
we're hearing go go against us. So we need,
you know, we're not going to change our, our
persuasion or what we want or our goals. We're
going to go find a media that will tell us
what we want.
I want to get your take on the degree to which
you think education is, is a, is a factor
here. And I'll give you an example that might
be a good lens into it. So the Trump tax reform
plan passed a couple of years ago and one
of the things that it did is not only did
it change tax rates, but it also changed the
default withholding tables. Meaning that when
you fill out your w four for your employer,
you put, I have one dependent, the default
amount of tax that was withheld during the
year changed and you very quickly had a lot
of people saying the tax cuts worked. I've
got more money in my paycheck. And then at
the end of the year you might've had someone
who had $100 more in their paycheck per month,
but their tax return shows $1,500 short. So
in reality they lost $300 net. I have, I have
argued that if we start teaching critical
thinking, basic financial skills, epistemology
early, like I say at age 12 in seventh grade,
that a lot of those very base talking points
that are effective in politics would be far
less effective. Am I overstating the importance
of the education piece or,
yeah. This is a really interesting question.
It goes way back and I've been, I've gone
back and forth on this. I have, I have come
down not on the other side. Obviously teaching
young people to think critically is a great
thing. I mean obviously, I mean I don't know
that anybody would be against it. I do think
it's a fantastic idea and I do think especially
in today's, you know, media and information
environment, it's just a juggle. So absolutely
people need to be better equipped to, to navigate
it, but I ultimately don't think that we're
ever going to get to a place where we have
created a kind of a like a super soldiers
who become, you know, immune to this stuff
or, or, or can't be fooled by those stuff.
Ultimately, I think relying on individuals
to navigate this is, is fruitless because
all individuals ultimately, no matter how
good of skeptical thinkers they are, everyone
is subject to these kinds of biases and these
kinds of cognitive flaws.
Everybody wants to be told what they want
to hear. Like that's not a, that's not unique
to any particular kind of person. Everyone
sort of, especially if you're just in sort
of like the, the rush of your day to day life,
you're just not going to like hone in and
analyze on every single thing that comes out
of the, the TV, you know, to sort of assess
it yourself. You just don't have this kind
of cognitive energy or time. So, so to me,
ultimately the solutions got to be in our
institutions. We've got to build self-correction
and self checking into the institutional rules.
So for instance, I, I think of science, you
know, [inaudible], I don't know if you've
ever met scientists. They're not super humans.
They're not, you know, they're, they're just
normal people. They have in their day to day
life, they have all the same cognitive biases
we have.
They're not super reasoners to work through
some of the facts of science. They have the
rules. It's like Guild. It's like a Guild
almost. There's Guild rules. You have to,
your paper has to be peer reviewed like everyone
and the whole point of the exercises for everyone
to constantly be questioning everybody else.
If you did that in normal life, you'd be a
jerk, right? But in science there are these
rules. That's how we do things. And so what
makes it work is collectively, right? It's
not that any individual scientists and superhero
is that collectively by correcting one another
and checking one another, you can help eliminate
some of those biases and blind spots and sort
of grow up your way towards the truth. And
it's the same for journalism or sort of name
your institution. It's, it's important to
have good institutions and rules and self-correction
mechanisms built into your institutions.
Cause if that breaks down, ultimately everybody's
just going to retreat to their tribal corners,
right? You're not going to, they're not going
to reason their way through it. They're just
going to a tribe that they feel safe with
and say, I'm going to believe what these people
believe. Right? I mean, people feel anxious
with uncertainty. They feel anxious when there's
no trusted source of information and they
go looking for comfort. And that's what kind
of this sort of tribalism is that, that we're
seeing so much today. Once you lose these
trust in these institutions, it kind of becomes
everybody for themselves.
When you look at the antidotes so to speak,
you're, you're sort of alluding to it here
by saying that there has to be some system
that doesn't depend on any one person having
the sort of, uh, determination to handle it
themselves or to think through it themselves.
Can you give us in the limited time we have
left, just a couple of examples of what that
might look like.
Well just take, just take journalism and the
rules of journalism. I mean as you learn them,
like you can't just trust one quote, you need
a second quote to backup your first quote
because the, the first quote, um, might be
a flawed in some way or it might've just,
you found a quote that told you what you wanted
to hear and it might be the exception if you
go talk to other people, you might find other
things. Just little rules like that little
rules. Like if you find an error in your,
in your story, you publicly publish a correction
even though it's embarrassing to you and maybe
the institution, it's part of the rules that
we are transparent when we get things wrong.
Just little bits and pieces like that little
rule, Guild rules. People see those in operation
and it gives them comfort that there's like
the structures in place that I can trust what
comes out of this institution.
And so I really think we need to be doing
two things right now. One is improving the
institutions, right? Like there was a reason.
There are good reasons people have lost trust
in our institutions. I think, um, you know
the sense that kind of they're rigged for
the benefit of the powerful, et cetera, et
cetera. I think all that stuff is, is valid.
So I think we need to refocus on rule of rule
of law and not have people write in democracy
in institutions to make those rules. And we
need to find some way of, of reaching that
30 to 40% of people who have sort of hived
off from mainstream society and, and bring
them somehow back into the fold. Cause I just
don't see how democracy survives if we all
know different things, if we're all effectively
living in different worlds. I just don't think
democracy can, can stumble on very long in
that condition.
That is a, that is, that is the great fear
and the great concern we've been speaking
with David Roberts who's a journalist for
box focusing on climate change in politics.
Check out his work will be linking to some
of it. David, so great having you on. I really
appreciate your time. Thanks a lot, David.